good afternoon this is matt welch of
reason TV i'm here at the beautiful
Denver Performing Arts Complex we're
just right next to us there's been yet
another panel discussion led by
Madeleine Albright who has been
everywhere in Denver this past week
talking about foreign policy there's a
strong difference this time around than
from 2004 and 2000 the democratic
national conventions in that the topic
du jour is foreign policy much more so
perhaps than even the economy various
panel discussions are extremely well
attended and there's a strong effort to
try to define what makes the Democratic
foreign policy in these times a lot of
libertarians and other people who are
weary of war are considering Barack
Obama for president sparsely because he
was against the Iraq war to begin with
but when you look for what people are
talking about building to replace the
edifice of the Bush administration that
they hate so much that's where things
begin to break down I have heard over
this past couple of days various things
such as from Obama's chief foreign
policy advisor Richard Danzig what we
need is a sustainable foreign policy
whatever the hell that means we had
William Perry former Secretary of
Defense talking about how we need to
give Russia the respect that it deserves
and then and only then will Russia begin
to behave and the topic du jour which is
when and what where and why and how the
u.s. shall intervene militarily that's
when you start to get some specifically
garbled answers so what we're trying to
do is find those things out and today
for example we had Dave waggle go around
and ask a bunch of delegates what they
think about when the US should intervene
and Dave what have you found out there
today I have found that these Democrats
are very faithful and they followed to
the word of their Lord and Savior Obama
a member was never against all wars he
was against dumb Wars like Iraq and
delegates I talked to basically agree
that Iraq was kind of bad we should get
out but if you mention anything else you
want the military to do there for it
they don't want to be seen as weak in
the face of John McCain's bellicosity so
there's really a
outside the hole i guess there's a
little bit of pacifism a little
non-intervention not so much for
delegates they kind of want rip-roaring
albright clinton ism to come back what
is the best example of intervention ism
that you saw supported out i would say a
lovely delegate from montana who talked
about how we need to control what's
going on in the philippines which is
good which i think john mccain has
fallen down the job probably hates
freedom thank you very much Dave the
Democratic Party national platform is
filled with various ideas about foreign
policy Mike Flynn today a director of
government affairs for reason has been
studying it and finding a things out
about Democratic interventionism
beginning in 2009 what did you say well
I mean the platform starts with what
we'd expect which is a drawdown from
Iraq and a pullout from Iraq but you get
the impression that we're pulling out of
Iraq just so we have the troops to use
elsewhere in the world interestingly it
introduces this doctrine that military
support should not only be used for
self-defense but it should be used to
respond in humanitarian crisis or
situation to mass atrocities so it's not
hard to imagine an Obama administration
that we'd have the hundred first
airboard in Darfur or in Harare Zimbabwe
it talks about our need to robustly
defend democracy around the world and
defend countries they're trying to
emerge democracies so I mean I think
what you what you have in my
administration should have a number of
instances of interventions but only in
areas where we have no self interest and
so it's almost like the motive is what
matters and as long as we don't have a
motive we should intervene militarily
thanks Mike speaking of motive i was
listening to yet another Madeleine
Albright speech this morning in which
she again set forth this very 1990 1990s
idea of that we are the indispensable
nation and once we restore our
credibility in the world which is a
shattered according to everybody here
then and only then we can begin to lead
the world and that's a natural role for
America to take there's some people
outside the convention who don't think
that's a natural role for America to
take Tim Kavanaugh spoke with some of
them today and what impressions did you
get it's again the the blank slate I
mean as we just heard the people who
want to intervene in all cases the
people who want to intervene wherever
it's bad for America
and the people who don't want to
intervene at all are all for Barack
Obama and believe that he is going to
deliver what they want to see I was
talking with some anti interventionists
who were you can see them in yellow
shirts about this color and they you
know even when you sort of pin them down
and get them to admit that you know
there's there's very little reason to
believe that Obama is going to dismantle
the military-industrial complex and not
intervene in Darfur and so forth there's
always this just you know triumph of
Hope over experience literally in this
campaign that you know we don't know
exactly what Obama's going to do
therefore he's going to do exactly what
we want him to go that's great Sam
tonight is some securing America's
future Democrats will be talking about
the foreign policy specifically Joe
Biden and Bill Clinton two of the
biggest late 90s interventionist from
the Democratic Party and from the
Performing Arts Complex here in Denver
this is Matt Welch for reason TV thank